hello everyone and welcome to another
really really wonderful game between
magnus cross and inaniponyshi we are
continuing our preparations for the
world chess championship match and again
a game from 2011 uh tal memorial that
was played in moscow between the
challenger and champion uh so it was an
incredibly strong tournament it featured
not one not two not three but actually
four yeah players that were rated over
twenty eight hundred at the time it was
uh magnus uh uh vishi kramnik and
arunyan uh and uh you know all together
it was an incredibly uh strong
tournament so this is one of the games
uh all games are uh of the classical
type format except uh for the one that
i've read in 2014 for some reason they
did not play a classical they played the
blitz tournament but other than that the
tall memorial tournaments are always in
classical time format so magnus has the
white pieces uh and he opens with e4
let's check it out we have c5 and this
is almost uh
almost 10 years uh yeah or rather the
the world chess championship match will
be like uh a 10-year anniversary to this
game i think it was even played on 23rd
of november uh so here knight to f3 uh
d6 and magnus goes for the canal attack
with bishop to b5 check we have bishop
to d7 and bishop characters on d7 with
check queen captures and now c4 so it
makes sense your opponent still did not
play knight to f6 your e4 pawn is not
hanging uh why not grab more space in
the center and really control that d5
square so knight to c6 and d4 now we
have captures captures in the g6
preparing tiffian cato the dark square
bishop knight to c3 by magnus and bishop
to g7 so you have to defend your knight
you could even move it knight e2 knight
to c2 but magnus defends it with the
bishop to e3 uh this is the usual way to
do it knight to f6 and now uh usually
when you have a situation like this
white will almost always play f3 and go
for the standard the queen d2 bishop h6
and so on uh but here we have h3 uh
a bit a bit of a rarer move then and
then f3 uh so magnus probably testing uh
how ian will fare in this
newly formed structure although i don't
think it was much of a surprise stay on
so castles castles uh and a6 by on
magnus plays a4 stops any uh b5 and now
uh the position has been reached before
uh even uh this year
magnus had it against wesley so in the
magnus crossed an invitational online
where wesley played e6 and that game
ended in a draw but here uh in this game
that was played 10 years ago uh rook
f2c8 was played and it is as of move 12
that the disposition has never occurred
again so let's see how
how are we to continue this well now if
the knight moves this c4 pawn could be
hanging so magnus simply strengthens it
we have b3 and only now e6 by nipple we
have rook to c1
and now as uh everything is fully
prepared uh nepo executes d5 and here
you do something that you almost always
do when black tries a d5 where in a
position where maybe d5 can't really be
played uh first you eliminate the
defender of the e5 square that's the
knight on c6 you capture it and the
after black recaptures it doesn't really
matter what with uh b captures was
played now you claim the e5 square you
attack the knight and the queen is
occupying the d7 square so the knight
can't really go to d7 you can't go to h5
because g4 just traps the knight so you
have to go to e8 and this is uh
maybe not the greatest of squares for
the knight but here it will uh serve its
purpose as you'll see so f4 of course we
have to defend our e5 pawn and now comes
a5 nipple says all right uh my knight
isn't maybe the most impressive of
knights but i played a5 i've located the
position on the queen set and now you
have this um backwards b3 pawn you can
never push it and i'm gonna pile up on
it with some with some rook here
along the b file so knight the e4 by
magnus of course the pawn cannot capture
the queen on d7 would hang and now you
see that this knight is actually serving
a fine purpose here it's not allowing
knight to f6 check
uh which could be uh you know quite
annoying as maybe black would have to
give up the dark square bishop and then
if you go up the dark square bishop i
imagine if it's not here i'm just gonna
try and hide it somewhere you know look
at all of those dark square weaknesses
uh so instead bishop to f8 uh gaining
more control over the d6 square for the
moment you have nothing to worry about
on the king side and rook to f3 now so
now magnus is preparing something like a
bishop to f2 then the rook can come to
d3 put more pressure along the d file
but also just adding another defender to
the b3 pawn if it will ever be needed so
queen to d8 now the queen is defended
and d captures on e4 is a threat so
magnus plays knight to c5 now says all
right my knight is looking very nice
here i'm also defending the b3 pawn now
many times and if you ever capture it
well then uh your dark square weaknesses
will really be
showing so rook seat the b8 nipple is
now ready to start uh his piling up
on that b3 pawn bishop to f2 introducing
another defender and now knight the c7
so for the moment you don't need the
knight here guarding these squares as
the white knight also moved from e4
queen to e2 uh and now comes rook to b4
uh now uh preparing maybe uh rotate the
b8 to put even more pressure on the b
file uh but all in all it's just a very
nice blockading piece here so king h2
magnus improves the position of the king
a little bit and now bishop to e7 uh
preparing queen to f8 to really make
magnus uh makes make his uh intentions
known we're gonna threaten the night so
whether uh he's gonna move the knight or
he's gonna have to play c captures on d5
to add another defender to the knight so
here we have rook to c2 by magnus
probably with the idea uh of playing g3
afterwards and then that will make uh
the the white king you know feel the
draft a bit uh so maybe this will serve
as a nice defender along the second rank
other than uh uh other than that i don't
really uh see the idea of rook to c2 and
maybe something uh you know uh in in
those lines but uh instead of rook to c2
uh white always uh has this g formal so
g4 is very very aggressive but if it
works it can be
uh you know it can really uh do wonders
for example if queen to f8 going after
the knight here now we can capture uh to
introduce another defender to the knight
and let's say knight captures now we can
push f5 and white is starting the attack
but he does have to open up his king a
little bit and this is a classical game
maybe it's a bit too ambitious but okay
rook the c2 by magnus and now queen to
f8 as planned going after the knight
knight to d7 now attacking the queen and
the queen to d8 magnus goes back and
nipple repeats queen to f8 saying all
right are you to repeat and magnus says
nope we're continuing the game c
captures on d5 now the knight is
defended
knight captures on the e5 and now g3 so
this is why probably this rook belonged
on c2 now you have additional support
across the
second rank as the pawns are no longer
guarding uh the white king so queen to
c8 now uh the c6 pawn is a little bit
weak so we have to you know
defend it in time bishop back to e1
chasing away near post rook rook the b6
and now rook to c4
so what do you play here uh well we have
rook a to b8 putting more pressure on
the b3 pawn and the now queen to d1
adding another defender and now only now
bishop captures on c5 other than this
there's really no good way for black to
try and accomplish anything here so
bishop captures on c5 rook captures on
c5 and now queen to f8 putting pressure
on the rook here and now what do you
play here well it seems like you could
capture the a5 pawn or you could not
capture the a5 pawn so what what should
you do here uh well it's very
interesting if you go after the pawn
then we have something like queen to a3
this is probably what nipple had in mind
attacking the pawn here and then if b4
uh the pawn is now nicely defended and
we open up a discovery to the black
queen the white queen is defending the
rook here uh queen eighty or queen to b
to check for example check we're gonna
play rook to f2 block check queen a3 and
now uh it doesn't seem like black has
sufficient compensation for this white
can even play something like f5 and it's
very very deadly for example he captures
an f5 queen d4 and there are so many
threats here uh that's uh i mean the the
pawn here is just nicely defended um
by the bishop and by the queen you can't
really start capturing anything if you
play some like knight captures on b for
just e6 and you are in big big big
trouble uh the black's position is just
falling apart even a move like bishop c3
can end in checkmate rook can come to a7
the pawn is just a monster here so it
could very easily open up so here after
queen d4 black would really have to
uh really really play well to survive a
position like this so i think uh this
was an invitation uh but uh you know the
one that uh magnus should have gladly
accepted but it seems that nepal's jedi
mind tricks worked on magnus and magnus
just defended his rook he played queen
to c2 and now nip immediately put a
knight on b4 saying uh all right now uh
you will not be capturing that a5 pawn
so bishop captures on b4 rook captures
on b4 and now we have rook captures on
a5 so the pawn is now captured but it's
a little bit different because now we
have queen to d8 going after the rook
here rook to c5 and now
uh well it's just uh the the the matter
of uh
uh explaining why why you gave up the a5
pawn now uh so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find uh a forced
forced draw for nipple while i give you
a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting either of
the two moves uh rook captures and b3 is
the first one and it's a pretty
straightforward one and if you went for
rook the d4 that just means you are a
truly an exceptional player because rook
to d4 is also a fourth draw but only if
you are a machine uh so i guess mostly
we went for rook to b3 but the dose who
went for rook to d4 you you are user or
a machine
uh so congratulations to everyone uh now
we're going to show both of them but
first we go for the more complicated one
because that's what you guys enjoy the
most so after rook to d4 we're obviously
threatening rook to d to check to win
the queen white will block this and now
we're going to play rook to d1 uh asking
uh white what do you what do you do here
so regardless so we're gonna infiltrate
the position with our queen with some
like queen to d4 to keep an eye on the
b4 square but if white uh as there's
really no way to push this white can
capture the pawn and then we go into
this queen d5 threat and checkmate rook
to g2 blocking and now even queen to f3
now threatening queen f1 the queen to h1
checkmate and then white will say okay
that's not going to work i'm just going
to play f5 and after queen to f1
threatening checkmate now we're going to
play rook c8 check rook captures queen
captures and after king g7 even this so
this is why
a sort of a computer is draw a kink to
h6 we're going to play queen to f8 with
check king to g5 now h4 check king f5 g4
check king captures on e5 queen to c5
check and even king to e4 and it's
looking very very dangerous here if
something like uh king to f3 comes could
be extremely dangerous because the rook
can block the queen's checks so you'll
you're gonna have to play something like
queen to c4 going to
queen trade captures captures and now
let's say rook to a1 rook to c2 guarding
your past pawn and now rook captures an
a4 so for example c5 king d5 c6 we're
going to play rook to a8 and
c7 rook to c8 and now you're going to
stop the pawn we're going to play king
to d6 pick up the pawn and this is uh uh
this is the the draw so this is i'm sure
some of you had this in mind uh but the
more likely outcome is just rook
captures on b3 this is what nipple
played and now there's really nothing
better magnus has to capture we have
rook captures on b3 queen captures on b3
and now just queen to d2 with check king
h1 queenie one check king to g2 and
queen to e2 check and he was in this
position uh on move 40 that magnus and
never agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here nipple will
just repeat kiwan king g2 or king h1
queen king h2 and then we're just gonna
continue checking because we are down a
rook so this is a truly truly impressive
game and uh i'm wondering if nepo niepo
is maybe the only one in the world who
could do something like this the magnus
and in
pretty much all of the games were magnet
where nipple defeated magnus uh he
always pulled off some sort of a jedi
mind trick and here uh was um well it
was no different here uh where he
allowed magnus to go for this but uh
magnus uh
just did not spot it here after queen to
f8 he offered the a5 pawn but it's uh
very very complicated it's very very
dangerous magnus refused the pawn uh and
with it his chances of pushing for for
the win so magnus of course became much
much stronger in ten years uh but so did
nipple so we'll see what happens in the
world chess championship match uh this
is their clash from the 2011 tal
memorial hope you guys enjoyed that
uh so yeah uh once again uh really hope
you guys enjoyed that uh i would like to
thank marshall farrier jean francois
bond matthias bollinger
uh oliver nius and the hoodie guy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
is happening in the chess world uh so
thank y'all i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day and i just
forgot i forgot uh i i remembered i
forgot to show you the standing so here
are the standings of this tournament uh
let's just enjoy that for a second as
well uh so yeah there you go guys magnus
won it with five and a half uh all right
tied with levon aaron but magnus had the
black pieces in five games and levon
only had the black pieces in four games
so that was the tiebreaker why magnus
won the tournament and nepo here with
five out of nine so half a point behind
uh magnus and
lavonne uh followed by uh vasily manchuk
and sergey karyakin and then
vishwanathan anand peter swiddler uh
boris guy from vladimir and hikaru
nakamura uh that's it hope you guys
enjoyed it uh see you soon